quedan pocas horas para que concluya la
contienda electoral más agitada en los
últimos 20 años en Turquía el actual
presidente regia verdon aspira la
reelección su intención de volcar el
sistema político Turco al
presidencialismo y su creciente
islamismo han deteriorado la situación
de Derechos Humanos en el país la
ventaja política que le dio el resultado
de las elecciones parlamentarias fue
usado por la mandatario para desafiar a
su oponente
señor
si es elegido presidente hay algo que
pueda ser después de no tener el apoyo
del parlamento nuestra Alianza Popular
tiene 323 legisladores en el parlamento
cómo piensa apoyar los proyectos de ley
Perdón midió sus fuerzas en Estambul
frente a una multitud de Seguidores
el presidente también cuenta con el
apoyo de sinánogan quien quedó de
tercero en la primera vuelta el 14 de
mayo y cuyos votos provienen de una base
social de derechas y nacionalista misma
base social que el segundo aspirante de
la presidencia que malcristaroglu ha
tratado de persuadir con su discurso
antimigrante
este viernes en un mitin también desde
Estambul cristal oglu basó su Campaña en
la recuperación económica
la situación en la que se encuentra
nuestro país en este momento no es buena
Turquía necesita salir de esto
reemplazaremos Un gobierno autoritario a
través de medios democráticos
con una inflación que alcanzó el 85% el
año pasado el poder adquisitivo es un
tema decisivo en las urnas